hello and welcome pensively Bucanero
from from Spain and I absolutely have to
stop the bleeding and losing three games
in a row that's not good most of them I
had pretty good positions as there's a
bad thing so when blundering before you
know don't give me that ah he stopped
taking it he's not taking it okay it's
quickly cover the cover stuff yeah yeah
let's see this is a somewhat annoying
pin um yeah it's always difficult to
judge if black should play g5 or not I
actually never know always struggle with
this question
yeah it seems to him also not be obvious
to him the black certainly can play
something like 337 and be somewhat okay
27 row that 17 miles love may be
allowing me to play 22 to this looks
dangerous to put it put it mildly so
let's open it up this is a check check
so not f five wins the Queen probably
black resides you know yeah I think your
mouth slipped with Queen to d7 that
cannot be a wanted wanted to move let's
say and nothing nothing terrible here
for black if we ask our friend stockfish
you can play as I said Emma can he can't
do that i'm not sure if it's good but
it's always an option for black but if
you don't want to begin the position
like that something move like this can
never be too terrible black has decent
pieces should be okay the engine gives
me slide a [ __ ] with one bit yeah
actually blundered if I am probably with
92 yeah and maybe not actually an idea
for okay yeah that that's quite useful
that that's am I get it I get it back g7
and so on so that was a blunder in a way
but not a blunder it was an oversight
but it doesn't doesn't leave me into big
trouble yeah 26 this is probably using
yeah like if I cannot cannot save this
anymore just attacking here and DF file
doesn't work it's probably miss click I
think you wanted to go to e7 something
to say about the opening by the way this
is the classical variation Bishop to c5
I castled a little bit too quickly
actually I think c3 is probably the most
precise move to prevent any 94 action
the way I did it to you got a 94 which
okay isn't like it's super great but I
think black is happy to trade I mean
what I mean is I'm not make Catholics
Allah mistake like a spare
294 this is a desirable exchange
normally I think there is this move by
the way I saw this at least once looks a
little bit like an Evans gambit Joe if
we I mean something like this definitely
looks interesting the position gets
opened up quite quickly anyway guys
thanks for watching